[Musique]
les gens me demandent pourquoi
risquezvous la
mort pour
moi c'est la
vie bienvenue à New York quelque chose à
déclarer j'ai l'intention de tendre un
câble entre les de tours du World Center
et March
DESS bonne
chance que j'a et quoi que je fe j'étais
toujour enê de l'endroit idéal pour
tendre mon
fil
j'ai besoin de ton aide pour y arriver
j'ai qu'
vousut c'est
parti r je trouver le moyen de faire
passer le
[Rires]
fil je crois qu'on devrait
reporter c'est totalement illégal sans
même parler du
danger
[Musique]
ma tte estine de dout au moment sur le F
je sais pas j'arri à faire le prier ce
que tu dois
faire ce mec est
manifestementingl est là pour
regarder ce n'est pas un jeu PhIP si tu
fais la moindre erreur tu
mouras